[Music]
hi gentleman's quarterly or as i like to
call you gq i'm paton oswalt i'm a
comedian i'm an actor i'm a writer and
today i'm gonna break down my top five
and bottom five science fiction films so
here we go
[Music]
look before we go do the bottom five i
don't enjoy trashing movies anymore only
because i've made enough movies to know
that even the worst movie on the planet
someone broke their back trying to make
it someone loved it someone wanted it to
be good and sometimes they don't come
out good
so
a for effort but your thing sucks let's
trash here we go
[Music]
we will not go quietly into the night
we will not vanish without a fight
we're going to live on
we're going to survive
today
we celebrate our independence day
independence day okay look independence
day on the one level is so freaking
entertaining it is a really big fun i
saw it opening day people were losing
their minds i was cheering along with it
it's just an example of a movie that
they ask so many buys of you there's so
many like i understand that the aliens
seem to be there to just destroy this
planet and take the resources although
after you destroy the planet how do you
get the resources i don't really
understand that part but the fact that
the big crucial third accene
where they send a computer virus to the
alien's computer which again this is way
beyond any technology we have it's like
that'd be like hacking a smartphone with
it with a manual typewriter like you
can't
but then there's a i found out later
there's a scene that they cut out of the
movie which i don't know why they cut
this out and it's a really quick scene
where one of the scientists says
actually we captured some of their
spacecraft back in the 50s and 60s and
we've used their technology to build
cell phones computers so our technology
is kind of like just have that one line
in there so then oh that's why they're
loading the virus up i get it that makes
it so they were so excited to have like
three more seconds of explosions that
they took out this one element the
filmmakers so didn't trust that we could
deal with
five seconds of dialogue that would
explain something they were so worried
about not shaking keys in front of our
face for five seconds they left that out
and that's always like left a bad taste
in my mouth
[Music]
log mr spock's starfleet commission
reactivated list him as science officer
both
effective immediately
star trek emotion picture is
so it's oatmeal colored uniforms on a
gunmetal colored ship everyone's in a
bad mood nothing really happens they get
to this thing at the end where it's a
voyager spacecraft but it thinks it's
god you're like i've seen this plot a
million times but i think that was a
plot of the star trek show i'm glad that
star trek the motion picture exists
though because it is such an absolute
failure in adapting the source material
that it made them go make wrath of khan
the rather con should basically be
called sorry about that first one here
here's the second one it will make it
really good i don't think you have to
have expertise in the source material
but you have to have a sense of fun and
a sense of joy know what at least what
the core of the engine that makes a tick
is and know how to use that that you
need it's beige people on a gray
background in a bad mood for two and a
half hours that's what they should call
star trek the motion picture
beige trick
[Music]
oh god
oh my god
is somebody trying to tell me something
[Music]
phenomenon is so annoying because
they they deal with some genuinely
intriguing concepts which is what would
a superpower super intelligence look
like in someone who did not have them
before it's this weird kind of flowers
for algernon but without the medical
treatment that makes them smarter but
then it feels like the movie
gives up in the third act and says oh
all the powers that he has it was a
brain tumor don't worry about it and
then we'll cut it down he'll be normal
again like it's just this weird like we
we took in this really intriguing
journey okay and we asked a really cool
question oh nice well this will be i
don't worry about that wait what no i
want no no wait it's just a humor we're
done great science fiction
doesn't ask amazing questions to then go
action not come to think of it don't
worry about it
[Music]
deep blue sea
i don't totally hate deep lucy because
it has a moment that i still won't spoil
if you haven't seen deep blue sea that
when i saw it the pact theater gave the
scene a standing ovation i think you
know the scene i'm talking about however
it's another one of those things with
independency where they're asking you
for a buy that is so ridiculous if you
think about it for more than a second
which is uh saffron borough's character
wants to cure
alzheimer's good
noble effort
so she has found a technique it doesn't
cure alzheimer's it slows alzheimer's
the side effect is
in order to get this slowing treatment
sharks become super intelligent
so to stop
grandma babbling about people that
aren't there anymore our oceans are
filled with genius level killing
machines that does not seem
like a good trade-off like and no one in
the movie is like wait no you can't
yes obviously we want to cure
alzheimer's but that's insane you what
are you doing they'd be like going i i
have invented a scratch-free linoleum
and in the process of doing so uh cancer
is now airborne and contagious but but
the linoleum will never scratch it's
worth the trade-offs no it's not worth
the trade-off it's just the weirdest
thing to have
in the middle of a movie with some
really lame special effects some truly
great surprising scenes
and a great last line of dialogue from
ll cool j
so i'm very very torn by it
[Music]
on the beach look
i know it's stanley kramer adapting a
neville shoot novel and i know it's very
important
but
um it's one of those movies that
unfortunately there's nothing worse than
the movie where it knows how important
it is so the whole underlying attitude
is you're welcome
the characters are all basically they
know that they're doomed they know
they're gonna die and i don't i don't
want to sound mean but some of their
last dreams they want are kind of dumb
like fred astaire wants to win a motor
race who cares and and look there have
been plenty of bummer
post-apocalyptic movies and tv shows
threads testament the road but at least
in those movies people were struggling
to to do
something these everyone in this movie
is like just get it over with and then
you as if you were like yeah get it over
with why am i sitting here you you don't
even look like you want to be in this
movie have a couple of foolish
characters in the movie at least that
are like oh no i know i'm going to die
i'm going to still try to live even
though i know i'm going to end up puking
my spine up and losing all my hair i'm
going to at least try i'm going to try
to do something here everyone in this
movie is like i'll just grab this one
last order race and we'll all have
poison then we'll be done like then why
did i have to watch this
top five
[Music]
do you know the klingon proverb that
tells us revenge is a dish that is best
served cold
it is very cold
in space
the reason i pick wrath of khan is
because it was such a corrective for a
bad science fiction film not just a bad
science fiction film but a bad way
to adapt material of someone not paying
attention to what made the original
material great and then part two was
like
no this is why star trek is fun and
awesome and lasts and we're gonna lean
into this aspect of it and it's just a
great reminder that you can massively
screw up and then correct it even if
you've never seen the show or don't know
any of its mythology it is such a lean
basically revenge thriller and in the
middle of it they somehow have a pretty
solid argument about not only do we not
have the right to take life do we have
the right to create it on a planet-wide
scale but again that's all in the
background what's what's on the top is
two insanely
hammy performances by ricardo montevonne
and william shatner basically trying to
out top each other a great way to have
an argument
about man's rights to create or destroy
is to have two
scenery chewing actors make a buffet of
it
[Music]
hasta la vista baby
not a necessarily original idea it was
uh borrowed heavily from
two episodes of uh the outer limits that
harlan ellison wrote soldier and demon
with a glass hand but basically it's a
really deep meditation not just on
fate and can you affect your fate is
your fate predestined but also if you
know what's coming in the future and you
know that the future is doomed it would
drive you insane how far are you willing
to play along with acting sane so that
you can then
function in the real world and maybe try
to stop the future but
everything i just said
pales in comparison to these
genuinely amazing special effects that
by today's standards the amount of care
and craftsmanship what was so brilliant
about terminator 2 is terminator was a
huge hit and which it's an unkillable
robot who was here to kill someone and
switch the future so they subvert their
own genre that they kind of created in
which now the terminator that we're used
to has been sent back and is unable to
kill he's there to protect we don't know
that that that always drove me crazy
when they they cut the trailers together
they made it very clear that arnold's
there to protect the kid but if you
watch the movie it's structured that you
don't know who the good or bad guy is
until the last second when they're in
that hallway and arnold protects the kid
get down
and schwarzenegger's character is this
what could be worse than a human being
that's a sherman tank that just can't be
stopped i know what's worse a human
robot that's a porsche basically that's
sleek and fast that can outrun the tank
so there's a whole other level of terror
to this
[Music]
oh my god
closed captioning not
make contact available earth and the
government is trying to suppress this
information and keep it away from the
normal people that have been contacted
basically the richard dreyfus character
who his performance is incredible he
basically becomes a true believer but it
shows you the cost of believing in and
knowing for a fact that something way
bigger than our current reality exists
it makes it really hard for him he's a
family man he loves his wife he loves
his kids but it's hard to take your kids
little league game seriously when there
are
massive forces that you know exist that
are trying to contact you you see him
withdraw from the world because of what
he now knows and it's so weird how that
seems to be happening in both evil and
good ways to a lot of people we're
living with now close encounters is
about the disintegration of a family
despite all of the big special effects
and the wonderful chandelier spaceship
and all the lights and all the sounds
there's a tragedy at the center of it a
family is destroyed and the father
leaves the planet it's really difficult
as a dad watching that movie now but but
seeing how brilliantly it's done how
brilliantly they nail it the special
effects of something like close
encounters i think are more effective
now because
they have a more genuine sense of wonder
because
it's not just a shoulder shrug and oh
they did it on a computer they had to
figure out how to build these models and
integrate them with the film you're
watching and make it seem like that's
happening your sense of wonder matches
the character sense of wonder when they
see these things it truly is something
miraculous that they managed to pull off
[Music]
good thing
good ain't human frank
what i love about fire in the sky is it
in itself is not a great
science fiction film overall but it has
a sequence that is so good
and so frightening and it's the closest
i've ever seen on film to what it would
be like to encounter an alien culture
and alien technology where i mean i
would guess to a neanderthal um a
cigarette lighter or a typewriter would
be terrifying like to just look at those
things moving it's so beyond what your
brain knows so there's a scene where a
character is taken aboard an alien
spacecraft and they do experiments on
him what is so eerie is how
unhurried the aliens are when they're
doing what they're doing to the
character and they're also clearly
following
a set procedure they're not torturing
him they're just doing they would do
experiments like you would tag a bear in
the woods but a bear getting hit with a
dart and having a tag would be
terrifying and so it's a human you are
now a bear in the woods being tagged and
it shows you what that would feel like
but what makes it so brilliant is he
only remembers this tiny sliver of the
experience and he can't quite put it
together and we can't put it together so
it's one of the best depictions i've
ever seen of what it must feel like to
encounter not just an alien culture but
an advanced technological culture
we have two notes
one that was written here and one that
was left on the door
if you didn't and if the other hue
didn't then who has been leaving the
notes
coherence uh is a little
micro-budgeted science fiction film that
was shot in
uh five days uh basically in one
location
a very
tense
taught science fiction thriller that is
done with basically no special effects
no
fast cutting but you're on the edge of
your seat the whole time watching a very
simple thing happen science fictionally
in which
reality fractures there are now
different versions of yourself and
different versions of overall reality
out there that you can just go walk into
if you want what do you do with that
knowledge what is the danger of that
it's a lot like another film called
primer where
it's more about the idea and how it
affects human beings rather than the
special effects and the whole visual of
it it's amazing
gq thank you for letting me go through
my top five my bottom five science
fiction films and if you watched all of
this thanks for hanging out with me i
know i got kind of annoying there in the
middle but uh i do appreciate it